stephen fry you could have been the hot
priest because is this true you
seriously went to have a a meeting about
becoming a priest yes yes when i was a
teenager i
you know i loved so much about the
church i love the music i love the
liturgy not a catholic priest an
anglican priest of course i lived in the
country beautiful architecture um
wonderful music everything about i just
fancied the clothes
um i knew i could deliver fantastic
sermons yeah um so i was sent to see a
bishop the bishop of lynn the african
bishop of glen who decided that i would
make a wonderful priest if there weren't
one small problem and that is that i
didn't believe in god
everything else so i failed at the last
moment i love that it got that far yeah
that you've got a meeting with a bishop
yeah no one had asked you about the
jesus thing yeah
yes
[Music]
well i i j and i still do i mean i you
know i love i love church music
and and and i love the buildings i love
everything about it i just can't quite
take the whole story seriously well i
know i just i take it seriously but i
just don't um yes this is the final leap
yeah there's probably quite a lot of
vickers watching going yeah
look at my house
look at stephen right now because you
were one of the earliest people on
twitter you kind of really picked it up
but now you have a kind of love hate
thing are you wanted at the moment or
often oh yes i'm on it i've been on it
for so many years still i i i suppose
the difference is now that i don't
really engage as much you just can't so
if you think of it as a notice you put
the notice up on the notice board and
then you run away before watching
anybody read it so i don't get you know
the the it's what's it's the comments
the unkindness i i'm very sensitive it's
pathetic after all these years that i am
but i i liken it to a swimming pool
people always say to me oh but 99 of all
the comments you get are very friendly
and nice like yeah but if you said 99
percent of the swimming pool is clear
there's just one little turd in the
corner i still wouldn't get in the pool
it just ruins it for me unfortunately
on the harry potter audio books oh lord
don't yes well i i mean i love doing the
harry potter books and how many hours of
harry potter have you done in total i
can't remember it's seven books isn't it
it's a lot and they got longer and
longer each time yeah um from the first
one onwards and uh
joe rowling was very
convinced from the beginning that they
should not be condensed or abridged they
should be absolutely i should written
them because she figured then quite
rightly i think a lot of children would
read them with their fingers going along
you know they'd listen to them rather
their fingers following the text and
that was a good way to reinforce reading
apart from anything else so
on the third one i think it was called
the prisoner of azkaban there would just
happen to be a three-word phrase that
for some reason i couldn't get out of my
mouth properly it was harry pocket did
it i still can't say it harry pocketed
it harry potter and i was i'd when i was
about 10 minutes harry potter did the
engineer was laughing everybody was
laughing uh i said look we'll park that
i'll try and solve it at
lunch time now at lunchtime i called up
joe running because she wasn't in the
studio and i said would it be all right
if instead of saying harry pocketed the
didit could i say harry put it in his
pocket which i can say easy and she
i could almost hear her smiling and she
said no
and not only that in the subsequent four
harry potter books she made sure the
phrase harry potter to do
[Applause]
now talking of children's favorites
harry potter the the audiobooks how many
hours of harry potter did you have to
read
over a hundred isn't it i i
well of course when it started um my
agent called me up and said there's this
book called harry potter and the
philosopher's stone that's what it's
called in england
america's sorcerer obviously
philosopher's a rather frightening idea
[Laughter]
[Applause]
anyway it was a book and and so i read
it and it was there was this boy and
apparently he was a wizard and i i met
the author who's called joe rowling and
she was really nice and and we read the
book and she said all right i've
actually there's another one there's a
second one i've written i said good for
you
little realizing what happened over the
years this extraordinary phenomenon
blossomed there was a and i loved
reading them occasionally people said
there was a man stopped me in the street
not long ago and he pointed it shouted
across the street my children go to bed
with you
let's not forget your marvelous work in
one of the most successful british films
of all time that film is spice world
yes
there you are
doing your cameo
do you have any memory of that day at
all it was done at the bbc that's all
uh because that's all i can remember um
in the bbc lobby i think i'm curious
because i had nephews and nieces and if
i hadn't done it they would have killed
me exactly i could get their autographs
that's how huge they were there was this
period when they were bigger than
anything on the planet
exactly and and i remember victoria
beckham came up not beckham she wasn't
then victoria whatever she was then adam
adams
i think
that's
she read one of my novels she said you
wrote a book called the hippopotamus and
i've just felt enough completely i just
thought what a pretty stylish clever
woman
whatever you think these spice girls no
they've got something i think
and actually i remember
the prince of wales
it was before wikipedia so how would she
have looked it up but the um
there was a the 50th um uh there was a
special show for the 50th birthday of
the prince of wales prince charles and
and they were on it and i was i'm seeing
it or whatever it was hosting it and
there was a lineup afterwards
and they were i mean they didn't care
that was all girl power you know and
prince william wonderful lovely thank
you so much and and he got to them and
the first thing emma bunting um said to
him yeah she said she said oh sir sir hi
mr sir um do you have a prince
albert and
he said
i mean his great great grandson yes
no do you have one he said well he's he
was the husband of queen victoria no but
and he looked at me completely baffled
and he didn't know what a prince albert
was so i had to say well sir it's a it's
an item of
intimate jewelry
so what do you mean
i said no further south
of prince albert i
and said
was like oh my he had to have a lie down
but
i admired the the spunk as it were to do
you know too
australian would put it you know too
it's an icebreaker yeah
to ask him i think we have a picture of
the moment he met them there he is
well that's me in the background yes
everyone seems very distracted by jerry
mr just pointing at her
absolute-mindedly
he actually he did tell me i don't i
think it's okay to repeat this but
prince willis did tell me once that the
best piece of advice his father had ever
given him he said when uh when you're
doing a photograph and
you're doing a lineup and there are
women always look only into their eyes
don't for a second that your eyes drop
to their chest because that's when the
photograph goes on and if you look he's
not looking down all the rest of us even
ask gay boy he's looking
very smart
[Applause]
during hamlet there was a guy who uh
lifted up his laptop not his phone his
laptop started doing the emails
do you know that story about john
gielgud who he was at rehearsing with
someone and and they put a pause in he
said oh no he must never pause in the
west end never pause
and they said why not he said i paused
once and it was i thought it would be a
wonderful silence and it was filled by a
voice in the back row saying oh you
beast you've come all over my umbrella
[Applause]
can you quickly tell the people the
story of christmas oh well which is
amazing i did a line-up for a show once
and
it was a there was a royal presence and
um the prince of wales said um
apparently you live in norfolk is it
right i said well i i do have a place
he's not uh not far from uh sandringham
in fact which was the where the royal
family had a house he said oh wonderful
i said you should come visit me for
christmas um you said they'd be loved it
loved it lovely idea of course i thought
they're more about it and that christmas
i had a real house full of friends about
14 people all squeezed together and i'm
a very early riser i'm very much a lark
not an owl and so i was up and i was
making eggs benedict i remember
distinctly and hollandaise sauce is a
very you know you have to concentrate
you get the the um the melted butter
into the egg yolk you have to really
thin steady stream the phone went so can
somebody answer that
please somebody with no they're all the
14 people showering shagging whatever
they were doing
and nobody was i'm sorry oh i picked up
the phone yes
can i speak to stephen fry please and i
said yes this is he and he said mrs
prince of wales here and it's up my
brain a little part of my brain sent a
signal to say oh [__] off rory
[Music]
another part because you always know
when it's someone real another part just
overtook it and went oh hello sir he
said i was wondering about taking him up
for that offer for tea
i said well that would be wonderful
when would you like when it's convenient
for you he said well what about new
year's day so i said well that would be
fine so i kind of put the phone down and
thought right i went into the hall and i
shouted a bit like rick in in the young
ones house meeting
everybody's appeared at the top of stair
heads and i said the prince of wales is
coming uh for tea and then everybody
went oh my god and then there was this
fantastic site um which i could have um
i mean i could have photographed i
should have done of everybody you lorry
hoovering the carpet
so we're all making tea or getting ready
everything's the fire's burning
everything's completely ready and we're
all peeping out to the curtains like
pathetic children like that all these
cars passing in and then eventually two
cars criss crunch everybody's
disappeared except me
so i the doorbell goes and i think i
must play it cool
otherwise you'll think i'm really uncool
and so i count to 15 and the bell goes
again and i open it and he goes oh hello
i hope you don't mind i brought my wife
and there's princess diana comes out to
the shadows
who's hello stephen
hello and everybody comes down um and we
have this tea party and it's fantastic
and she's wearing cowboy boots which
suits very well he's not wearing car
boots which suits him very well
it all goes fantastically everybody's
having a great time um
and then they go and he says thank you
everybody says goodbye and she holds in
the doorway
and she says i'm sorry we're going but
i'm quite glad we're going early because
it's spitting image on tonight
and i'm going to watch it in my room
they hate it of course but i love it
when i'm in america i have a tesla and
it drives itself so it has an autonomous
mode so it's wonderful you have friends
you can scare the living daylights out
of them by being on the freeway and then
you know they don't see you
you just pull the stalk back three times
to go into auto drive
and then you just think
you know look at the book
and they're going to keep your eyes on
the road no i can't be bothered
and he drives itself another one you can
do as well good trick is uh is if
someone if your passenger falls asleep
which i hate because you've got to do
the driving there's no one to talk to
i i wait till they start waking up again
and i close my left eye
lucky it's perfectly safe but they
absolutely
[Music]
you